what's going on Jim how you doing it
where are you right now man Cali man are
you really so they have to wake you up
for this or do they have to wake you up
for this or are you already up doing a
press tour no I'm uh press tour and
working out brother go to the gym that's
what you call active you really are tall
your body looks as good as it I commend
on your physique more than you think
Kevin who's more active you were or the
rock because that way I follow that
Instagram and the rock seems
extraordinarily active you know what I
can honestly say we're both along the
same lines but at different times of the
day like mine's is more consistent early
in the mornings his fluctuates he'll do
a couple of early sessions but he'll
also go late night late night as well so
he's not waking up to do it all the time
I had to wake up and do my top of the
morning so monitors and at 5:00 a.m.
5:30 a.m. range on a daily basis
everything it would be mine not mine way
better than him rich rich voices
correcting you that rich voice just
corrected your grammar Kevin with rich
rich balls has the body and anything
listen to me listen to me first of all
calm down all right don't get all big
come your big comeback Kevin said you
look like an old woman in your big
combat guys no no I look I'm ripped come
back you know it has to be a comedian
we're having a conversation I know you
I'm trying to say - Kevin is he
challenged me and like an [ __ ] he
said I'll give you 500 dollars to 100 if
you could do a two-minute plank and like
a [ __ ] I said I'll just do it without
the BET and I [ __ ] did a 2-minute
plank I could have won 505 you didn't
take the bet because you had no faith in
yourself which you should know I didn't
have $100 and when you saw that you did
it you actually shot
[Laughter]
none lipo I know he's had like no have
you had liposuction now I would do it
though I would do it he has they put
they put the thing between his ears and
they suck out the weight to minute play
I can't do it I could probably like I'm
a minute maximum Frank
yeah I can't plank for that long for the
[ __ ] down there I would say this about
both y'all as much as I love trashing
y'all and giving you guys as much as
possible I can honestly say as you guys
got older you really started taking care
of yourself because you saw a serious
the health side of it was boss you are
an amazing shape Jim you really did get
it together and start taking care of
yourself you headed down a weird road to
you had gained weight
it just looked weird yeah yeah it'd just
it just didn't match I just didn't like
the way look that is another seven thing
you did say something first of all I
look like Chaz Bono and you did things I
think you [ __ ] came in I told you
Kevin was one of the guys who really
made me because I hadn't seen him in a
while
and it was he sat down he just went your
face is getting fat and I remember that
I'm like oh my god it was such a natural
thing for him to say oh my god be Kelly
in studio how come he like why oh why
cuz I'm sticking up for you you don't
have to stick up for me I look I'm
saying it motivated me to work out
because I realized if you some what you
don't see the first thing they teach you
about is you look fat and you're natural
like wow I really got to do something
but you you're working out you you see a
listener so they don't think that I'm
the evil person guys don't think that
I'm just out of tackle people because of
the way it's different this is my friend
and our pole is to give each other the
maximum amount of [ __ ] as possible so
getting on each other's skin is what we
do seeing Jim's face and realizing that
his face with like the turnbuckle in the
wrestling ring by the way that's how you
know Kevin is a movie star because he's
we've been trash to each other for
[ __ ] 15 years and he's going like look
first of all I'm not fat shaming it's
like yeah you have to say that now
because you are famous then they'll pick
up that you're a fat shaming and they'll
come after you for it
this is just me and my friends joking
naturally what I'd love to do is
motivate and inspire and I think
regardless of a person's weight and size
that has nothing to do with their mental
it's all about a mental man if you know
that you're doing the right things in
your life to get healthy then ultimately
you're putting yourself in the best
position to not only win but live for a
long time and that's what it's about to
see my friends get healthy and I'm
talking about gel and I'm talking about
June rich that's a big deal man because
when our lifestyle in our environment
we're not in the healthiest surroundings
well well fast food we're around jump
around alcohol cigarettes whatever it is
whether there's drugs whatever your
poison is it comes within a lifestyle
that we live so we make that choice to
live it the right way I think it's
better so to see the guys do that I
applaud you for it man I think it's dope
as hell to see you guys but I do have to
tell you Kevin cuz I don't know if
you've hung out with Jim recently cuz
although physically he is in good health
mentally he is not even remotely in
terrible terrible placement it's always
been a sick dude he's always been a
weird a weird guy there's a different
level of sick in there and Kevin is
promoting by the way the irresponsible
tour which just how many days you just
had a hundred new dates across over 100
a hundred date we're doing you know this
is a global tour domestic international
I wanted to release it in a big way
release the tickets today they all go on
sale man and you know this is a this is
my best hour and twenty minutes of
material to date this is me being real
authentic raw putting my life out there
on display as honest as I possibly can
and I think you know the reviews are and
people are loving it and the production
the show just the whole vibe that goes
along with my tour is one like like I've
never done you know I love to outdo
myself ultimately we're our own
competition and when you realize that
it's all about just being better than
you are today before well I just want to
make sure that this tool is better than
my last one that's bigger and that that
title committee rocks
is one that people will understand when
they come and see the show well may 27th
Kevin's give me the PNC the 28th is
Prudential Center July 29th Nassau
Coliseum September 27th at MSG tickets
are going on sale today these shows will
always sell well they all sell out
Kevin sometimes will do multiple arena
shows in the same city sometimes just
one so it's not a problem - will they
sell out it's just a matter of just get
the tickets first so you have them you
gotta choose recently - buddy about
being it's amazing it like how people
take SNL monologues and make more out of
them than it's just a comedian trying to
be funny and you you know you get called
sexist just because you're doing
parenting jokes
listen if they're not talking about you
- you're doing something wrong we live
in a world where social media is giving
people the power to voice their opinions
and sometimes those opinions get
magnified simply because of a click of a
button simply because of the power of
retweet when your feed into that stuff
you give it more energy than what it
deserves it's nothing you also really as
a comedian know who you are you know the
content and context of the things that
you're talking about some people just
love to speak some people just love to
have something to say those who will
always exist I don't let it bother me or
affect me or my craft you know it's it
comes with the territory in today's time
is that simple yes I understand the
generation and what goes with the
generation and clearly it didn't yeah
controversy that's just something that's
in today's time that you'll have to deal
with regardless and it's always good
when there's that like social media
outrage and it really doesn't affect you
because you didn't acknowledge it and
now you and I mean Jumanji came out
after that and it still did eight
hundred eight hundred million were alive
a controversy hurt us it just went like
week after week people were like oh Star
Wars and Star Wars had one week every
week after Star Wars it was just - mangy
Jumanji Jumanji Jumanji yeah incredible
I think I think the work the work speaks
herself okay I mean when you talk about
the S&L it was I believe when mines came
on outside the worlds that just came
warm which did amazing numbers minds
like one of the highest-rated that they
had for the season
you know the Torah speaks for itself the
shows have been selling out left and
right you know the movie box office
results speak for themselves I mean
you're looking at another number one
movie that falls under your belt so I
said it to say people are always going
to talk it's my job to make sure I do my
job to the best of my ability I'm always
trying to do it at a hundred percent and
nothing less and the results are always
going to speak on behalf of your hard
work when you understand that and know
that all that other stuff means nothing
you have to let people talk you have to
let people say the things that they're
going to say that comes with the
territory what people feed into that
stuff you become a part of the problem
instead of being a part of the solution
the solution is exhale you to move
forward and show people that you're not
one of the weaker entertainers that let
these things get tool and you also uh
laugh out loud is launching a Sirius XM
24-hour comedy channel which is uh it's
gonna be early this year do you you
don't know what when that's actually
gonna happen we're actually going to
launch on Valentine's Day February 14th
man excellent allowed I'm going to have
my own channel you know this is
something that I wanted to do underneath
the brand of my own digital network and
the fact that I can have a serious
channel where people will get to hear me
and my show weekly literally my my
topics and things that I see you do Jim
it's such a high level of the things
that I've seen Howard Stern you know
when you talk about Opie and Anthony all
of these peoples I've seen just doing
amazing job on the radio as a comedian
that's an outlet that we can always
shine on because you know we're
opinionated and we have clever ways to
get our opinion across so to have the
opportunity to do what you guys are
doing and still pursue my career as a
comedian as well as an actor as well as
a producer and and CEO it's an amazing
thing I'm just trying to pull them as
many hats as possible okay we also got
on line for Bob Kelly wants to talk to
you Bob is calling in we didn't know bob
was going to call in so Bobby you're on
with chemical
to get the breath machine ready somebody
please hang up on this mini Oprah I be
first of all first of all Bobby what's
the food down is next to you can you
call in the middle of chopping down a
waffle speeches is annoying me don't you
talk to mr. Hart that way knowing you
Bobby Bobby you know why it's annoying
you because this is what success sounds
like I wish I could say that to you
Bobby I'm not a Bobby will want me to
sound I'm professional and Bobby you
would love to see things fall apart
Kevin and what what okay why don't you
help me out watch help me lose some
weight why don't you take me under your
lost Kevin did you do that no oh can we
lie we lost Kevin's that was the actual
comedy gods no see we can get him back
we lost him by mistake I'll talk to Ron
but yeah he called us we didn't call him
well the number was on the thing no I'll
have it down Irene
all right you okay try to get him back
you way our apologies would you say
Bobby let me say Norton yeah a piece of
[ __ ] thank you I'm not even on the radio
and he's got to throw a [ __ ] sack
thing at me Bobby stomach rumbling yes
you did
and then Norton you go I was sticking up
for you and Norton goes I don't need you
you know what Bobby what I say I don't
need you to boss here's I don't Bobby
all right I was thinking coming back on
I know it's fun to hit oh my god I need
Sam you can't get Kevin the back on he's
back on now yeah which is we just we got
disconnected oh so we're picking up yeah
hey Bobby all right Kevin you're back on
sorry okay yeah guys I don't want you to
think that we got disconnected I hung up
[Laughter]
because I did what my fans would think
that Bobby Kelly was associated with my
tour his voice can hurt my ticket sales
so I hung up the phone immediately
thought about it and I said maybe it's
okay so I'll call him back
so Kevin on your channel you doing a
show are you doing your own show are you
just playing comedy clips no no I'm
doing my own show
I'm doing my own radio show oh okay he's
got a weekly my whole show yeah once a
week and if you want to leave myself and
my guys open for me me and a plastic cup
boys and we'll have a weekly show okay
we would debate another day to be able
to Friday or Saturday we want to go live
30:14 for sure Kevin the guy's an open
for you I heard good things about them I
think maybe I have some opening dates if
you want to squeeze me in just for a
little bit of a flavor you know I'm
saying you know what we know about your
opening dates those opening dates are
called the rest of the year I had a guy
open for me that opens for your guys and
he was selling candy bars after the show
[Laughter]
any bars with his [ __ ] picture on it I
go get a CD or at least a shirt he was
selling candy bars you know what it is
i'ma tell you something man I've yet to
change our core group the reason why man
we've been together from the beginning I
know these guys like the back of my hand
we know each other's behavior nobody's
doing us and stupid if it's
bloke you don't try to buddy so true can
I get the guy with the candy bar to open
for me I know Elena [ __ ] you're just
handing the money over here sorry I ate
your [ __ ] not get your merch
[Laughter]